last week after jesse smallett was
sentenced to prison for perpetrating a
ludicrous race hoax in chicago the
actress brother made one last
impassioned and implausible plea
for his brother's innocence
there is absolutely no evidence linking
jesse to staging his own hate crime
besides the testimony of two brothers
claimed jokey smolette
now of course
there was lots of evidence there was the
testimony of the attackers who were not
white racist gay bashers but in fact
nigerian homosexuals there were records
of smilet having paid the brothers there
were records of the nigerian brothers
purchasing the tools for the hoax there
was security camera footage and there
was of course the sheer implausibility
of white trump supporters even
recognizing the little known actor while
prowling the streets of chicago claiming
it was magga country
and attempting to lynch smolette while
he somehow held on to his subway
sandwich
lots and lots and lots of evidence and
yet
jesse is having the last laugh
now that he has been released from
prison after just a few days
and he convinced an appeals court judge
to free him by you guessed it
playing the race card smilet's lawyer
argued quote there is no room in our
court system for
politics
regardless of what you think about this
case the real question is
should black men be walked into jail for
a class 4 felony
yes
the answer to that question of course is
yes men of all races should be walked
into jail for felonies but that wasn't
the question at all
the question was should black men be
held to lower standards by society if
they play the race card
should we let psychos and criminals off
the hook
if they can make even the most dubious
claims to be victims
in a sane society in traditional society
in mega country everyone is equal before
the law
but in our unjust society
jesse smilet goes free and so does his
attacker i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from crystal swiger
who says i'm a daily wire member and
i've already watched the first
installment of the dr fauci series i
hope you release this to the public one
day because this needs to be heard by
all people maybe you can release it on
dvd for sale thank you so much i'm so
glad you watched it this was a little
bit of a stealth project we didn't do
much marketing or advertising about it
we've been working on this for months it
is a three-part series telling you the
behind-the-scenes story of dr fauci you
remember national geographic did this
hagiography of dr fauci a couple months
ago the wonderful angelic dr fauci well
we're giving you the real story going
back to the 1980s
this stuff has not been seen before so
go check it out at dailywire.com right
now it's called fouchy unmasked one
great way to watch it is you go you sit
down right the weekend's coming up you
sit down with your little honey you
maybe pour a glass of wine
you turn on the fouchy documentary and
you sit down with a nice juicy steak
from good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles i have got the best opportunity
for you to fight inflation that you will
see anywhere in the country you're
seeing inflation especially at the
grocery store right now things like eggs
milk meat especially going through the
roof good ranchers prices have stayed
low and affordable they have not just
the ability to
let you buy meat and ships to your house
it's really top quality meat they've got
that but you can also subscribe when you
subscribe to x amount of meat per month
your price never goes up
i don't mean never goes up like for the
rest of the year i mean for the rest of
your life
your best price is locked in
for life for extremely top quality meat
i was eating good ranches
steak just what was it about three four
days ago
no i had the hamburgers three or four
days ago i had the steak last i eat good
ranchers constantly it is phenomenal top
top quality meat get your 30 discount
right now on prime steaks and better
than organic chicken today go to
goodranchers.com knowles to save on the
quality you've been looking for good
ranchers takes the guesswork out of the
grocery store they source everything
from local farms ship it to your door
use code knowles enjoy your box of 100
american meat 30 in savings lock in that
price forever go to good ranchers right
now american meat delivered
so smallett
perpetrates a hoax he gets caught
completely dead to rights he is
sentenced he makes a big crazy scene in
his sentencing and tries to make it all
about race and says he's a black
political dissident
you know who's being persecuted by the
government
and then his lawyer goes in and plays
the race card even more and says black
men shouldn't be arrested for felonies
that's his argument white men that's
fine asian men yeah throw them in the
can but black men black men are so super
duper special they need to be held to a
much lower standard and what happens the
judge agrees with him and the judge lets
him off the hook race is this magical
little thing that you can play that will
get you out of anything there was a tick
tock that just went viral of
of a young deluded white liberal woman
explaining
how everything is racist
including
including eating meat
how is eating meat racist
i'll gladly tell you
looks like we've got an oppressor on our
hands
so during slavery times
slaves did not get to eat the same
things as their masters they got the
scraps that no one wanted chitterlings
now that black people have overcome
slavery they developed a rich barbecue
culture to make up for all the
meat-eating that they lost out on
so when you go to the store and you buy
a piece of meat as a white person you
are actively taking away a piece of meat
that could be being enjoyed by a
survivor of ancestral slavery
eating meat is not only racist but it's
also anti-semitic during the holocaust
jews did not get to eat meat in labor
camps they ate potato soup which would
spill on their bodies
burning them and giving them infections
now
jew survivors eat a lot of meat brisket
just let them have that stop
appropriating
when i first saw this i will admit i
thought it was satire
i don't think it is satire i think this
girl is is being serious
and there are so many levels of comedy
here
the first one
obviously not everything is about race
not every but except everything sort of
is about race i've said on this show
before racism
just means bad that they are synonyms in
modern culture when people say racist
all they mean is bad when people call
you a racist all they mean is
i do not like you you are a bad person
it can have nothing to do with race
because we have decided that that is the
only sin
is racism and we don't even use the
language of sin anymore and i think a
lot of that is because
race is only skin deep and we live in
this world where we're so absorbed by
materialism that we've got to make
everything about matter and so you say
you're racist it just means you're bad
but then of course the next layer of
comedy here is the the woman is saying
things that traditionally would be
considered pretty racist
you know she goes listen you insensitive
meat eaters you're taking away some of
that good old ham hock and chitlins from
those black people you know black people
they just they sit around and they eat
their collard greens and bacon you know
they're sitting on the front stoop in
alabama somewhere eating cornbone and
you think hold on lady are you is this a
minstrel show what are you talking about
i think black black people eat sushi too
did you know that black people go they
can eat italian food too they're people
just like you and me they say black
people anytime you eat barbecue which is
that's what black people that's black
people food okay black people eat their
black people food and you white people
you can eat
i don't know umami or something i don't
what do white people eat you can eat
tofu salad and the black people and jews
are going to eat brisket and if you eat
brisket you are
basically a holocaust denier you're a
it's all about it's all about race
it's an it's an extreme example but this
is the kind of thinking that you see
going on and it's because we've confused
ourselves and made every single thing in
the entire world about race which is
it's it's the thing in american politics
that you cannot touch there's only one
word that you can't say
you can go on tv you can say the f word
you can say s-s-h-i-t
you can say the c-word on tv okay i
don't because this is a wholesome family
show but you can do it people have said
it on tv there's one word you can't say
there's one word you can't even write
anymore what is that word it is the n
word which is treated as more sacred
than the holy name of the lord by the
ancient israelites okay that's the word
because race
is the most taboo the most sacred issue
at all and so it's no surprise that we
make everything things that have nothing
to do with race become about race
including
supreme court nominees
so there was a memo that just came out
from the gop
it was a big warning to republican
senators
about this new biden senate nominee
biden said i'm only going to nominate a
black woman i'm not going to look at
other candidates i'm not going to pick
the most qualified person
i'm only going i'm going to limit myself
to six percent of the population and
then i'll pick the best person from
within that six percent and the person
he ended up picking is a woman named
katanji jackson
you are going to hear her referred to as
katanji brown jackson this is just a
minor point i don't i don't want to give
people three names
it really drives me ruth bader ginsburg
no you get two names you get a first
name and a last name it's ruth ginsburg
it's amy barrett it's katanji jackson
katanji jackson is you know on paper a
qualified candidate she's always going
to have this little asterisk next to her
nomination because the president who uh
nominated her began the whole process by
saying i'm picking a diversity hire so
that's sad for her this woman's worked
very hard her whole life she's very
intelligent by all
appearances and she's always going to be
seen as a diversity hire
but the gop is terrified of her and
they're terrified of her because she is
black
they're terrified of her because the the
left
if the
senate republicans in any way criticize
this woman they're going to call them
racist so there was a leaked memo that
came out
that said
during justice kavanaugh's confirmation
democrats lost the battle of public
opinion when they launched vicious
personal attacks against him and paid
for it electorally so don't launch those
vicious personal attacks against katanji
jackson which is going to be really hard
for us
to avoid doing because she raped me
she katanji jackson raped me at a party
in the 80s i have exactly as much
evidence of that as christine ford had
that she even ever met brett kavanaugh
and that other lunatic julie swetnick
had that she even ever met brett
kavanaugh truly no evidence there
uh so yeah it's gonna be really hard to
avoid that because of the abuse that i
suffered at the hands of katanji jackson
you can take that to the bank
now
the republicans
are making an argument here they're
saying look don't don't get personal do
not get tough on this nominee it's going
to blow back on us if we do that just
like it blew back on democrats except it
didn't really blow back on democrats
democrats looked like schmucks during
the kavanaugh debacle they they really
looked awful that's true and we talked
about it all the time but it didn't hurt
them at the ballot box they didn't pay
for it how did they pay for it the the
kavanaugh
nomination process and confirmation
process was 2018.
began in the summer of 2018. you then
had the midterm elections in november
2018. democrats picked up 41 seats in
the house
doesn't look like they paid for it there
republicans held on to the senate they
already had the senate they picked up a
couple seats in the senate so fine but
you're talking 41-seat swing pro-dem in
the house two-seat swing pro-republican
in the senate doesn't even change who
who runs the senate and then the
governorships democrats picked up seven
seats
seven different states for governors so
it didn't work democrats got tough it
was very distasteful
and they won it actually helped them
republicans shouldn't do something wrong
we shouldn't lie we shouldn't be immoral
but we should get tough do not run away
from this i know it's the worst thing
you can be called in america is a racist
they're going to call you a racist
anyway so if you're not doing something
unjust if you're not a mean cruel awful
person then who cares what they say let
it roll off of you get tough do not just
roll over for the democrats
do not do not roll over for people who
mean to do you harm that's true on the
political
sphere it's true
at the level of your home and your
family which is why you got to check out
american home shield right now go to
ahs.com
knowles some of the threats to our homes
it's not just the bad guys lurking
outside sometimes it's just electricity
sometimes it's just your appliances
breaking people don't like to think
about household breakdowns but they
happen way more often than you would
like that's why it pays to have a plan
from american home shield to help cover
the costs to repair and replace things
like your heating system
like your ac like your fridge they know
that no two homes are the same that's
why they have new options to help you
find just the right coverage if american
home shield cannot repair the covered
item they will replace it american home
shield members get more more coverage
options fewer exclusions from hvac
systems and plumbing to kitchen
appliances their plans help protect
parts of up to 23 essential home systems
and appliances coverage is available no
matter how old your systems and
appliances are cover protect yourself
today keep your home up and running and
budget on track with american home
shield right now our listeners can take
fifty dollars off their most
comprehensive plans ever go to ahs.com
knowles
save 50 bucks ahs.com knowles 50 off any
plan american home shield be sure with
the shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply seat plan for details
speaking of the united states senate
great news
in the u.s senate
they have voted to end the mass mandates
on public transit now
the bill's still got to go to the house
and nancy pelosi is probably going to
kill it there joe biden is going to
probably try to kill it if it somehow
made it to the white house but the
senate
which is 50 50 republican and democrat
the senate voted to end the mass
mandates
this vote was brought by rand paul
republican
he brings his resolution and gets a 57
to 40 vote
meaning eight democrats
voted to end the mass mandates there was
only one republican who voted to keep
the mask mandates guess who it was
i well
this is a little bit of a trick question
because i called this person a
republican his n he has the the letter r
next to his name when they talk about
him but i am speaking of course about
mitt romney failed senate candidate in
massachusetts failed republican
presidential nominee then he moves to
new hampshire to try to run for
president doesn't work then he moves to
utah becomes a republican senator and
consistently votes against republican
priorities
so i used to say that mitt romney was my
favorite democrat in america but that's
i don't think that's any any longer true
i think these eight democrats who voted
to
end the mass mandates i think they might
be my favorites and what unites almost
all of those democrats
they're up for re-election
they're in tough seats where they could
lose and what this tells you is despite
all their protestations to the contrary
even the democrats know the people hate
these masked mandates
whatever polling that is put out there
by the mainstream media
the democrats know what the republicans
what we have known for a long time
the people hate these masked mandates
and when the politicians have to face
the people they will vote against the
mass mandates if they feel that they're
insulated from the people they've got
two or four years until their next
re-election
then maybe they'll vote to keep it
but the democrats know people are sick
and tired of kovid
they're they've they've sidelined dr
fauci he's in a hidden bunker somewhere
he's you know
i i zielenski in ukraine who actually
has putin's assassins coming to try to
assassinate him zelensky is more public
than dr fauci right now that is how
toxic fauci has become which is why i
would strongly recommend you head on
over to the daily wire check out fouchy
unmasked this is my three-part series
part two has just dropped today
the real behind-the-scenes story of dr
fauci how this man took power how we can
stop him from seizing power again after
the midterms which is very much on the
table please send it to your friends
appreciate that
the democrats are off the covet thing
they're now on to the ukraine crisis
and as for that zelinski the president
of ukraine spoke virtually to a joint
session of congress yesterday and
zelensky did not temper his
requests of the the congress
he actually came out
he said quote
this is a terror that europe has not
seen for 80 years
is this a lot to ask
for to create a no-fly zone over ukraine
to save people is this too much to ask
is it too much to ask if so we offer an
alternative you know what kind of
defense systems we need and then he asks
for aircraft
and anti-aircraft guns but his question
is is it is it too much to ask you
americans to put a no-fly zone over
ukraine
yes that is too much to ask
a lot of people don't know what a no-fly
zone means a no-fly zone means direct
shooting war with russia
a no-fly zone means
that you will have two nuclear powers
two major powers
one superpower one former superpower
directly shooting at each other the
thing that people feared would end the
world for half of the 20th century
the thing that we fought an entire cold
war and managed to avoid zelensky is
saying hey can you just do that can you
just do that thing that you managed to
avoid for
the whole the whole latter half of the
20th century the thing that could thrust
us into a global nuclear world war three
yes that is too much to ask
zelinski you've got my sympathies my
sympathies are with you my sympathies
are with ukraine my sympathies are not
with vladimir putin vladimir putin
doesn't like the west very much
but we've got to be realistic here
because though we might have the best of
intentions
to put a no-fly zone to get into a
shooting war with russia the road to
hell is paved with good intentions good
intentions virtue signaling reckless
foreign policy is what brought us to
this point
so yes that is too much to ask but some
democrats keep jitting up that rhetoric
some democrats are coming out like
democrat senator jackie rosen she says
this is our world war ii moment
i think we still need to support the
ukrainian people because
you cannot watch those videos i'm not
going to watch
i'm not gonna watch who am i gonna be in
this moment when i've watched world war
ii on tv eating a box of popcorn no
that's not who i am and that's not who
the american people are the entire world
like i said is watching
was only about 80 years ago that we saw
this happen
in world war ii the world is watching
what we do now i really believe this is
a moment there's few moments in our
lives personal professional and now this
is global where we all know where we are
and we all have to take stock of what we
stand for and who we want to be
remembered
to be and this is that moment and we
have to hold vladimir putin accountable
one of the most annoying consequences of
people not knowing a damn thing about
history anymore is that people only ever
compare political events to two
historical events
they either compare it to the fall of
the roman empire about which they know
nothing
or world war ii about which they know a
little bit more but still probably not
very much those are the only two
historical comparisons you ever hear
because people don't know a damn thing
about history anymore
there are other historical events
other things have happened in history
that might be closer analogs to what we
are seeing in our everyday political
affairs be they mundane or be they
extraordinary like this war in ukraine
what is this woman talking about when
she's not calling for a no-fly zone
she's not calling to send in the 101st
airborne she's not calling
directly for a war with russia
she's saying that we need to give more
military aid to ukraine
but we shouldn't put boots on the ground
we shouldn't do the no-fly zone she's
not just
because this is world war ii
putin's hitler
is he
is do you do you senator jackie rosen do
you really believe that this is if you
really believe this is world war ii
then we need to go to war don't we we
need to send our boys into ukraine we
need to if you really believe putin is
hitler we need to do everything we can
to stop him right
not just give them a few extra airplanes
or not even that not even give them a
few extra guns and missiles we got to
send in the marines don't we it's world
war ii after all putin is hitler the
man's hitler what do you would you have
said in world war ii well hitler you
know okay we're going to arm the jews
we're going to arm the czechoslovakians
we're going to arm the poles with some
extra rifles
but we don't look we're not going to go
in or do anything
is that what you would have said
no it
you obviously don't believe that this is
world war ii
yet you obviously don't believe that
putin is exactly the same as hitler
you just don't know anything about
history and these people who have no
frame of reference no sophistication in
their geopolitical thinking they are the
ones who have led us to this point who
have squandered the post-cold war piece
and have brought us to a point where
you've got a nuclear former superpower
invading a neighbor after they were
literally invited to do so by the
president of the united states joe biden
world war what do they want what do they
think this is the the white house the
democrats the liberal establishment
can't decide they keep flip-flopping on
on all of this
are
we are we involved in this war are we
not involved in this war
the white house maintains that we're
going to ship ukraine a lot of weapons
but they're they're only going to be
defensive weapons and a reporter
i believe for cbs news
was having none of it even a reporter at
a left-wing outlet
came out and he said jen you were
selling us a bill of goods
you put out a list of all of the
military equipment included in that 400
million dollar 800 million dollars yeah
that's being provided to ukraine among
those items let me read them to you 100
grenade launchers
5 000 rifles
1 000 pistols
400 machine guns and 400
shotguns are you saying those items
are not offensive weapons they're
weapons that help the ukrainian people
fight against an invasion by a foreign
country they can be used offensively can
they not again their weapons what i'm
talking about is weapons that can be
used the answer is yes i mean although
you don't want to say it that answer to
that question is yes
and so obviously you're trying to make
this distinction between offensive well
what we're talking about let me finish
let me finish
let me finish let me finish my answer
look you weren't no i was finishing a
point and then you can respond to mine
okay go ahead all right you're making
this distinction between offensive and
defensive weapons anybody that looks at
that list of weapons that i just
mentioned they would say clearly they're
offensive
clearly they're offensive but what
what the white house wants to do is say
no no no all the guns and the missiles
and the rocket launchers they're only
going to be used for defense so we're
not being provocative in any way we're
not escalating this when we send all
these arms it's we're not doing anything
bad we're only doing we're not we're
both involved in the war and we're not
involved in the war well you know if you
stand in the middle of the road you're
going to get hit by a truck russia is a
big enemy we're going to be tough on
russia also russia if you invade eastern
ukraine we won't do anything russia is
instigating a new cold war and also
russia here have your direct pipeline to
europe so that you can invade ukraine
you've got to pick a lane sometimes a
bad decision even is better than
indecision but the the white house the
liberal establishment won't make those
hard decisions they they don't they
don't want to take the responsibility
they don't want to actually have to take
the moral risk of
picking a strategy picking a view of the
world and following through on it this
is the consequence of fluid culture this
is the consequence of we don't need to
decide anything
about morality about the way markets
operate about the way we're going to
enforce our laws about the difference
between men and women it's all just kind
of fluid man and it's gonna change every
day frankly it's gonna change every
minute this is the consequence of it
changing every minute you can't you
can't violate the law of
non-contradiction okay the weapons can't
be weapons and not weapons at the same
time pick a lane stick with a strategy
if you want a great strategy to have
yourself feeling better i strongly
recommend you check out superbeats right
now go to superbeats.com knowles we've
got a new way to start your day super
beets heart shoes they are a tasty treat
that gives you the energy you need that
is good for you no more afternoon
coffees no more energy drinks no more
candy for that quick pick me up two
delicious plant-based super beets heart
shoes to your morning routine will
promote heart-healthy energy for your
day without a caffeine crash because
superbeats heart chews unique clinically
researched grape seed extract promotes
heart-healthy energy and normal blood
pressure as part of a healthy lifestyle
the grape seed extract used in super
bee's heart shoes has been clinically
shown to be two times as effective as
supporting normal blood pressure as a
healthy lifestyle alone do more for your
heart treat yourself with super beats
heart shoes head on over there right now
we love it here at the daily wire
i've got to keep the staff members from
stealing them when they come in for our
listeners only you can get up to 45 off
plus free shipping at superbeats.com
knowles this is the best offer available
anywhere superbeats.com knowles get up
to 45 off superbeats.com knowles these
statements and products have not been
evaluated by the fda these products are
not intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease or condition
i've mentioned my series fauci unmasked
available now at the daily wire the
second episode concocting a crisis
dropped this morning it reveals just how
ineffectively the world's leading
disease expert handled every crisis from
swine flu to anthrax and everything in
between check out this sneak peek
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you wear a mask keep
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony thatcher don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
[Music]
the last part of this three-part series
drops tomorrow it's available
exclusively at the daily wire if you're
not a member yet head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
the show is terrific if i do say so
myself and since we're only adding more
content every day you do not want to
miss it also tonight is ben's third
thursday book club you still have a
chance to sign up he'll be taking
members through his analysis of a tale
of two cities by dickens this is a live
experience where you get to engage with
him like never before when you sign up
you'll also get his notes it's a cheat
sheet to the most important lessons
uh you are doing all of this with
thousands of daily wire members live so
sign up for the third thursday book club
at third thursdaybookclub.com to get
ben's notes
sent straight to your inbox for a tale
of two cities it is tonight at 8 pm
eastern we'll be right back with a lot
more
the flip-flopping from the white house
on this issue in ukraine has gotten so
bad that even within the span of two to
three minutes
joe biden can't decide whether or not
vladimir putin is a war criminal
yesterday at an event joe biden was
walking through glad-handing slapping
people on the back he was asked a
question by a reporter is putin a war
criminal here's what he says
so he changes his mind within
what was that there was a little bit of
space in between there but probably
within two or three minutes
and he pretends at the end that he
didn't hear the question the first time
but he very clearly does he walks up the
reporter says are you prepared to call
putin a war criminal he's looking right
at her he's very close to her and he
says no
no i'm not he walks away and then i
don't know either some aide whispers in
his ear or it occurs to him or he just
changes his mind he walks back and he
pretends he says did someone ask who
asked did i do i think that
yes do you think putin's a work criminal
and he pretends he says oh oh yeah oh
gosh oh of course i must have misheard
you i
thought you asked i don't know i don't
know how he could have possibly
misinterpreted the question he says yeah
i think he is a war criminal
if vladimir putin's a war criminal
if he is at if he's committing
gen what is a war criminal
it's not just someone who goes to war
it's not just someone who invades
another country
that's just kind of what war is
if invading a sovereign country
made you a war criminal we would have a
lot of war criminal presidents wouldn't
we no being a war criminal
has a higher threshold you need to
commit
war crimes you need to violate the
international law such as it is you need
to commit a genocide you need to
intentionally target civilians you need
to
order
rape and all those sorts of heinous acts
that occur during wars
is putin a war criminal i don't know
certainly lots of civilians are being
killed it would seem that the russians
are targeting civilians
not totally they're certainly targeting
civilian areas probably their argument
is well we're getting the militants who
are in those areas the women and
children are fleeing uh
that will have historians hash out
whether those russian excuses carry
water probably they don't but this is a
this is a big deal to call someone a war
criminal
i'm not sure that all of the evidence is
there certainly compared to other wars
and even if it is let's say let's say
that it is putin
is not exactly a virtuous guy okay he
does all sorts of horrible things so
let's say okay he's a war criminal
what strategic objective is accomplished
by
biden giving that answer
by him answering the question at all
right now you've got this war it's been
going on for 21 days in ukraine and it
would seem that the
the best thing to do assuming that the
america is not really going to give much
support is not going to go in it's not
going to get into a direct shooting war
with russia it would seem that the best
thing to do would be to give putin an
out to stop the fighting to stop the
shelling of these civilian areas in
ukraine okay how are you going to do
that
one way you could do that
is by negotiating a piece there have
been what three meetings now between the
top ukrainian and top russian officials
you could try to negotiate a piece where
russia gets to keep crimea they already
had it and russia gets to keep a couple
of those breakaway regions that they
originally claimed and the ukrainians
get to keep kiev and get to keep most of
their country and
maybe they agree not to join nato and
maybe they
demilitarize somewhat that would be hard
to do because they've had a lot of
weapons shipped into them and putin
pulls all of his troops out
and
you basically just go back to the stasis
that you had
before this war broke out and most
circumstances looking like they were
before 2014. okay is that perfect no but
it gives each side something to
incentivize them to end the war
right it gives zalensky an out he gets
to maintain most of his country gives
putin an out he gets to rejoin the world
stage maybe you lift a lot of the
sanctions off of russia and so everyone
can walk away
with their pride a little bit wounded
but they can go and claim a victory at
home and then most importantly the war
will stop
that's not going to happen if you if you
start calling the man a war criminal if
you call putin a war criminal if you say
after this war this guy's going to the
hague he is going to hang for his crimes
against humanity
well now putin has no incentive to stop
the war
right if you this is this is the
stupid side of canceling russia all
these companies pulling out of russia
going after the central bank completely
destroying the economy they russia now
has basically no incentive
to pull out of the war
but it makes it makes westerners feel
really good makes joe biden gave him a
good little clip on cnn it makes that
random democrat senator feel really good
i'm on the right side of history i'm not
just doing nothing no you're making
things worse is what you're doing which
is what biden and the democrats have
been doing the entire time they at every
single step of the way
they have made the situation worse in
ukraine
i am not some shock in awe neocon
they're going to greet us as liberators
warhawk belligerent kind of concern i'm
not i am about as far from that as you
can be
and yet
a little bit of strength a little bit if
he if if basically every single thing
that biden had done we just did the
opposite and frankly a lot of the
moves that
america and nato and the west broadly
had made in ukraine for the past 10
years if we had just done the opposite
i don't think this stuff would be
happening right now
but there's no there's no incentive for
that and frankly you want to talk about
a really dark political calculation this
war in ukraine is probably the best
thing to happen to joe biden politically
in a long time he's underwater on every
issue in his country it's an election
year he knows this is the one issue
where he looks somewhat not like a
complete and total failure because the
media are doing a good job hiding his
complicity in encouraging this war
and so
it's going to drag on and on and on
this is an amazing fact it just just
occurred to me yesterday it has been 21
days since the russian
invasion of ukraine
that is the same number of days
that it took the united states to invade
iraq
until the fall of baghdad
so the actual not the occupation and the
insurgency but the actual conquest of
iraq
took place in exactly the same amount of
time that russia has now been invading
all of ukraine
america did it
quickly efficiently completely russia is
stalled in this quagmire
roughly the same it's impossible to know
how many russians have died in ukraine
we're still in the fog of war
we're getting different numbers out of
the ukrainian and russian propaganda
shops but
roughly let's say it's six to eight
thousand russians have died
that is roughly the same number of
americans who died in iraq and
afghanistan
over 20 years
that's the number of russians who have
died in ukraine in three weeks
there are two lessons to take from this
one
america is the only country on earth
that can actually show force that can
actually go out there and accomplish its
military objectives
cleanly efficiently it's it's not even
close
we we we talk about how general million
and the top brass of the pentagon have
gone woke and they're complete jokes at
this point that's true that's pathetic
that we have to have our soldiers and
sailors and airmen and marines reading
ibram x kennedy and critical race theory
it's a joke
but the american fighting force is still
so many orders of magnitude beyond the
strength of any other force on earth
whether it's russia or anyone else it's
not even comparable it's not so that's
the first lesson
we still have
such an insane advantage on force that
we don't need to fear the militaries of
other countries exactly
but then the second lesson is what about
the consequences we went into iraq
because we knew
that
they were going to greet us as
liberators which they actually did by
the way a lot of iraqis were pretty
happy about the invasion
we thought it was going to take
a couple of weeks three weeks to
complete it it did that was all true and
then what happened we got bogged down
in a political quagmire for years and
years and years same thing in
afghanistan we got bogged down in a
political quagmire in afghanistan for 20
years that was not foreseen by the
pentagon that was not what the state
department told us at the outset of the
war on terror in 2002 2003
we went in with a great deal of hubris
we went in with a great deal of
confidence justified confidence because
we've got the strongest military ever in
human history
but what are the consequences here
fortunately in iraq and afghanistan
the consequences did not involve
a nuclear former superpower it did not
involve war throughout europe it did not
involve too many other major world
powers
what could happen here it's very easy
for jackie rosen to say oh yeah let's
just do i'm a good person this is our
world war ii moment yeah give give all
the weapons it's totally fine let's
escalate this thing it's no big deal
joe biden you go yeah putin's a war
criminal yeah sure let's escalate this
whatever i'm going to get a good clip on
cnn
what are the very easy
to start these things
what are the consequences going to be
speaking of war
brian stelter over on cnn is he's really
sick of a different war not the war in
ukraine he's sick of the culture war you
know these republicans
these conservatives they just keep
pushing their ridiculous culture war
agenda such trivial issues don't matter
at all they're on the wrong side of
history you know those republicans they
don't even want to trans the kids
when the media calls it a culture war
battle
isn't that the wrong frame for this it's
not a culture war to talk about equal
rights for everybody in a country i mean
i guess it is but this is especially
when there's a real war raging in europe
i'm getting tired of the culture
warframe i'm getting tired this isn't a
culture why are we calling it a culture
war
we're just right that's what he's saying
right when when
the left and squishy republicans when
they come out and they say oh enough
with the culture war what they're saying
is give the radical left everything they
want
they never tell the left enough with the
culture war they never say hey left stop
killing all those babies and radically
redefining marriage and chopping up
people's bodies and transiting the kids
stop maybe stop doing that they never
it's only at the conservatives
who are not the belligerents in the
culture or they're not the attackers in
the culture war
who started the culture war by
definition it's not the conservatives
the conservatives are trying to conserve
the old standards
it's the left that came in and said hey
we're going to completely change our
understanding of sex and human
relationships and family and marriage
and reproduction and babies and human
nature itself we're going to radically
change all of that and we're going to
let hulking husky dudes walk into the
girls changing room and if you have any
problem with that man i don't know you
got some weird hang up you're just a
crazy culture warrior enough with the
culture war just lie down and accept
what we tell you to do
no i don't think i will
i don't think i will
this issue seems to have broken through
in a way that marriage and some of the
other culture war issues in the past
have not this issue of transiting the
kids it has turned parents into a voting
bloc
parents who were liberal or independent
or
even
center-left they they have realized huh
i don't want little johnny to be told by
his first grade teacher that he's a
little jane
i'm going to vote against this crap but
that hubris i mean i guess this is the
running threat this hubris of the left
they're so confident of their own
ideology that in the long run their
ideology will prevail that no amount of
failure or human devastation will
convince them otherwise
this is true of of the sort of globalist
liberal establishment too you look at
the debacle in iraq the debacle in
afghanistan the debacle in egypt the
debacle in libya the very near i mean it
was a debacle in syria that actually
could have gone worse
and
and after all of that
the
globalist adventurists will tell you
well it'll work next time they're still
so confident oh it didn't work because
of this oh this thing went wrong oh this
but don't worry my ideology of global
markets and peace and harmony and utopia
it's going to work next time let's do it
let's ratchet up the tension in in
ukraine it'll work it's
it's that or it's what you often hear
from the liberals right which is an
implicit
who cares if it works in practice does
it work
in theory
abortion
leads to
horrible outcomes for everyone involved
and for society we've now got a dying
population you've got lots of depressed
women who have been in many ways duped
certainly enticed into committing this
horrible act you've got a million dead
babies a year almost 60 million dead
babies since roe versus weighed
and
and what
and they just keep doing it marriage
family totally collapsed poor little
kids now going on
cross-sex hormones mutilating their
bodies permanently disfiguring
themselves you look at all that carnage
they say no don't worry just a little
bit more of this it'll work next time
cut it out with your culture war saying
no to this no
no it's it's really easy for
conservatives to push back it takes a
little tiny bit of courage but
to overcome just the liberal
establishment but the people are on our
side here i get the gop's fears of these
things you saw it with the letter that
they wrote about katanji jackson the
supreme court nominee they say don't uh
just let this one go through basically
just don't get too they're gonna call us
racist hey let's just cool it here okay
guys just no don't don't don't buy it
don't give them an inch they've gone so
far their views are so toxic we are
doing so well in the polls right now the
people are so disgusted by democrats
failures on every single issue keep
pushing conservatives stand your ground
you know who's doing that
ron desantis down in florida ron
desantis
pushed this bill that the democrats
dishonestly called the don't say gay
bill it's actually the parental rights
in education bill and despite massive
pressure from the establishment from the
corporations from
all the libs from the media
desantis held firm he called their bluff
and it totally worked now he's spiking
the football
this idea that somehow people actually
said that if you don't have classroom
instruction on sexual matters in grades
k-3 that somehow businesses don't want
to be in florida i think people need to
get out of their bubble and actually
talk to parents in this state because
they do not want this in kindergarten or
first grade or second grade we want our
kids to be kids
these people got to get out of their
bubble and this is true of republicans
too the republicans who have been so
conditioned very often they live in the
beltway or they just watch a lot of the
news they watch the sunday shows
on cable news and they you know they
they read the establishment legacy
newspapers and they think oh i don't
want the new york times to call me a
racist i don't want chuck todd on that
show to call me this or that they're
they're living in a bubble
how many of you listening right now
listening on podcasts listening on radio
on youtube wherever you are how many of
you
regularly watch cable news
i do not
i do not i go on cable news a lot i like
i'm not i'm really not disparaging cable
news i'm glad to reach people who are
usually in a much older age demographic
but young people by and large don't
watch it i don't i don't have a cable
subscription
almost none of my friends who are below
the age of 50
have a cable subscription
how many of you
re you wake up in the morning and you
read the new york times
i don't i'll read articles from the new
york times throughout the day if they go
viral but i don't read the new york
times as my source of news i haven't in
years
even relatively conservative
establishment outlets
i just don't read them that much even
the wall street journal i was i you know
i subscribe i don't read it that much
for my news the the media landscape has
so completely changed and people have
access to information in a way they
didn't before
the fouchy documentary is a good example
of this
even five to ten years ago something
like the three-part voucher series just
really couldn't have gotten out there
there wouldn't be a platform to do that
that could sustain that kind of level of
production
you would have to turn to the bigger
left-wing outlets to get something like
that
now you can
do not fear beltway crowd bubble crowd
people the handful of people who still
watch the sunday shows do not fear that
and you are living in a bubble the real
political landscape the actual people
have changed listen to ron desantis okay
listen to glenn younkin in virginia
listen to your humble host who hates to
say i told you so
just stand firm all the bellowing and
screeching and rending of garments and
gnashing of teeth that you get from that
liberal echo chamber it doesn't resonate
out here
okay parents still
don't want to trans the kids it's great
news coming out on the so-called social
issues in west virginia the west
virginia house and senate
just passed a bill saying you can no
longer abort down syndrome babies this
is a real tragedy and it's something
that future generations are going to
look upon us
with horror
for they're going to look upon us as
though we're absolute barbarians and
savages
a lot of babies most babies who have
down syndrome that are diagnosed in the
womb
are killed through abortion this is why
you don't see as many down syndrome
people anymore remember 20 30 years ago
you'd see a lot more down syndrome
people now you don't see as many because
they're being killed in the womb
there's an even an irony to this which
is we covered this on the show a while
ago the vast majority of positive tests
showing birth defects in the womb
that very often impel people to abort
their babies or false positives they're
not even real
but furthermore even if they were real
you shouldn't be killing people because
they have disabilities that's the wrong
thing to do
what an evil thing to do and yet people
do it they don't even think about it the
the most virtue signaling moralizing
people in the world
the the most preening liberals on the
world who change their profile picture
to the ukrainian flag or to the mask or
to the rainbow flag or whatever the
cause celeb is of the day
to seem like the good moral people
they will walk into a doctor's office be
told their baby is [ __ ] and kill the
baby without even thinking like it's
obvi of course
of course well i don't have a little
perfect baby like i like no one is by
the way none of us is perfect but
they'll go in and they'll kill it in
iceland they bragged about this
a few years ago they they brag they said
we've eliminated down syndrome in
iceland
there's no cure for down syndrome you
just kill them all you're bragging about
how you're killing every single person
with this particular
disability before they can even make it
into the world so
this is a really great law that i assume
will be signed into laws passed by both
chambers in west virginia
it's a great law because look i would
much rather outlaw abortion
for everyone right there's no more
abortion we can't kill any of the babies
but when you point when you say you're
not allowed to kill disabled babies
that drives home the moral horror it's
what they've done on the education front
and instead of merely framing education
as we're going to ban critical race
theory or we're going to ban
transgenderism they call it curriculum
transparency
so now the left has to be against
transparency in west virginia they've
got to be pro kill the crippled people
kill the disabled people
that's not the place you want to be in
it's just another way of framing the
argument
to
show you the moral horror that people
are blind to because they don't
they're they're not being given a proper
formation or a proper moral view of the
world which is why i've got to get to
this i'm so happy to see this
there is a diocese of the catholic
church down in mexico that is now
denying communion and the ability to be
a god parent to pro-abortion politicians
i wish our bishops and priests here in
america would do the same thing because
it is scandalous the fact that our
president says that he's catholic he
blasphemously claims to be catholic and
yet he supports the slaughter of babies
which is a non-negotiable issue you
can't do it he is
truly imperiling his mortal soul
and he is imperiling the souls of people
who are scandalized by this and confused
by this so this this priest down in
mexico
in sinaloa he says that pro-abortion
politicians this is father miguel angel
soto gasiola uh the they will not be
able to receive the holy communion
because this is a recognition of their
objectively unworthy state to receive
the body of christ it's not the priest
punishing them exactly it's a priest
actually helping them say look you're
unworthy of this right now you are
harming yourself and harming a lot of
other people and the politic the the
priest comes in and says these
politicians cannot do it it is my job we
don't have that in america anymore but
we need a lot more of that when we had a
functioning religious
community in america and when we had a
functioning civil society this
constrained the whims of the politicians
and then in the name of liberation we
got rid of all that stuff and now we've
got totally unlimited government we've
got totally unlimited tyrants running
our country and it's it's terrible for
the state of our country and it will
lead to horrible political outcomes it
ironically will make us much less free
this is how you get people like dr fauci
go check out fatchadmasstonight we'll
see you back here tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire
on today's episode ukrainian president
zielinski addresses congress lawmakers
attempt to make daylight saving time
permanent and amazon pulls workers out
of seattle over rising prime
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire